all right microchipping oh god don't
even get me started on this I I just
cannot [ __ ] but like I just can't
[ __ ] believe this [ __ ] do you know
Delta Airlines wants to start using
people's fingerprints as a way for you
to get on the [ __ ] plane and do you
know that most people won't have a
problem with it they're so [ __ ]
stupid
it's like there's so many people out in
the world it's almost like you know what
dude why don't you just become a [ __ ]
slave like how much you gonna give to
these people how underpaid of
politicians that they will not stand up
to these people these corporations I
swear to God the Syd net wasting all
this [ __ ] time with Isis and all this
other [ __ ]
these [ __ ] corporations the mother
[ __ ] that they're doing to their own
goddamn countrymen which they really
don't have because they're [ __ ]
global they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything about just trying to make more
[ __ ] money and do they want they
gonna start microchipping people this
was a compass constant company to
implant mic implant microchips in
employees and like like five people
already agreed to it they're gonna take
something foreign that's not natural to
your body and they're gonna stick it
underneath your [ __ ] skin they're
gonna know where you are at all [ __ ]
times and all these [ __ ] does for
their you know the you [ __ ] problem
it's the [ __ ] problem okay just
because you're a [ __ ] dope doesn't
mean the rest of the world is okay I
think it's safe to say that me and
everybody else listening to this thing
for the most part was not as smart as
[ __ ] George Washington right fair
enough okay well here's the deal if
George Washington was microchipped and
all his [ __ ] buddies were microchip
this [ __ ] country wouldn't exist
because they would have known where he
was they would have gone over there and
they would have [ __ ] killed him and
that would have been the end of the
[ __ ] rebellion so what you're doing
is is you're having faith that these
[ __ ] people at the top who have not
even remotely demonstrated on any
[ __ ] level at any point in history
that they give a flying [ __ ] about
anybody other than themselves are gonna
you're gonna turn over that level of
power you're gonna get fingerprinted by
Delta [ __ ] Airlines like you've
committed some sort of a [ __ ] crime
if [ __ ] airline is gonna have your
[ __ ] fingerprints who are the [ __ ]
did they think they are do you know I
went to buy my car they asked for my
thumbprint I was like I'm not getting my
[ __ ] fingerprints to him you're a car
dealership
legal this is to protect you no it isn't
yet douche you're gonna sell this to
somebody it's part of my profile I think
they're just they're collecting they're
all sharing information about you what
you buy where you live what your social
security number is your [ __ ]
fingerprints they're gonna get it all
the way down to your [ __ ] DNA it's
it's I don't know and these politicians
will not push back on any level because
the president makes five hundred grand a
year
that's the highest paid political office
is five hundred [ __ ] grand a year and
they need a hundred million dollars to
get the job I don't have a hundred
million you don't have a hundred million
corporations do and that's what they owe
it to so they just look the other
[ __ ] way and what do they do they sit
there and they [ __ ] on [ __ ] comedians
constantly going after do you hear what
he said about Caitlyn Jenner and they
look the other way with pharmaceutical
companies handing out [ __ ] opiates
like they're giving out flyers to some
sort of jam band and now we got this
heroin [ __ ] problem they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't say anything about it
sorry I know I'm [ __ ] losing my [ __ ]
here but like what they've done to the
food supply what the [ __ ] they that what
the bankers have done left all these
people upside down in their own [ __ ]
houses what they've done to the water
supply fracking causing earthquakes in
parts of the world that never had
[ __ ] earthquakes [ __ ] up the
drinking water you know they got to send
a [ __ ] pipeline out of the [ __ ]
Native Americans land I mean like like
we haven't done enough to those [ __ ]
people
you know DEA or any politicians talking
about that now nobody talks about that
[ __ ] but God for [ __ ] bid you do a
[ __ ] joke in a strip mall and they
[ __ ] all over it then that becomes
like some big goddamn story this is
[ __ ] horrific and it makes me happy
then
years of age the fact that I think I'm
gonna maybe get to live half a [ __ ]
century without a [ __ ] airline having
my fingerprints and me walking around
with the goddamn microchip you know I
love that I lived 50 years before the
[ __ ] oh Jesus she's up huh
I love that got to live 50 years before
robots showed up it's just it's just
greed and power completely 100% out of
control and I hate like this is I'm
reading this this is eyewitness ABC News
so these guys are all bought and paid
for CNN's bought and paid for Fox News
is bought people they're all [ __ ]
bought and paid for because the same
people I just brought brought up they
advertise on their [ __ ] networks so
they have to watch what they say because
they don't want to lose the ad money cuz
that's how they get paid right so they
always have like down jeez this is a
little unsettling you know when they
always come back from it when they show
some [ __ ] robot you've ever seen egg
watched at the local news or they show
somebody getting microchip and they
always come back to the anchors they
kind of do that whoo it's kind of and
then they just move on to the next thing
but some [ __ ] old lady who makes her
own jam like that's supposed to make you
feel better at the end of the [ __ ]
newscast there's some puppy that they
thought was lost and [ __ ] sniffed its
way back to the station wagon three
towns away right whenever the [ __ ] they
leave you on now corporations are
completely out of control they've been
out of control my entire life and now
it's it's reaching a level that it's
like you're watching a bad sci-fi movie
I think it's [ __ ] insane why the [ __ ]
do you need my fingerprints as a [ __ ]
airline who the [ __ ] you you're not
the FBI
you're not the government you're a
[ __ ] airline your fingerprint and
this is the thing people will do people
will [ __ ] do all of this so they
don't have to stand in a line
they'll let them scan their [ __ ]
retina they'll give them a [ __ ] baby
just so they can be pretty checked
that's all you got to do you just hold a
little cookie out and the average
[ __ ] mouth bring them [ __ ] morale
but you know something I go - swear to
God I mean this is really cynical but I
you walk around and i40 got half the
[ __ ] people should be microchipped
you should know where these [ __ ]
idiots are I'll never forget that guy
galloping sideways on that Trump rally
screaming at all these stupid liberals
going [ __ ] political correctness build
the wall build the wall is he's [ __ ]
galloping like like that was gonna make
his life better like that was what was
holding him back I swear to God like I
don't give a [ __ ] how dumb you are you
have to know as a white dude if you were
born in the United States of America
okay you're not gonna get a better
starting block than that all right and
if you can't figure out some sort of gay
I mean if you're gonna [ __ ] blame
anybody why are you gonna look down you
got to go up that's what's [ __ ] you
over Democrats and Republicans [ __ ]
you over I just don't get how people
don't see that but I'm like most people
I feel like my ideas are right and no
one else has a good point unreal this
[ __ ] car dealership can we get you a
thumbprint it's like ya know you guys
sell cars you understand that you guys
lie for a living
other salesmen who live for a living
turn the other way you let you turn the
other way when they see a car salesman
you like that you like the bottom of the
barrel [ __ ] salesman yeah I'm gonna
give you my fingerprint you know why
they said they wanted my fingerprint
they go just in case somebody comes in
and tries to is an imposter and pretends
that they're you and tries to buy a car
and I just looked at the guy and I was
like you know what I'm gonna take my
chances on that
[Music]
[Laughter]
the guy literally goes in this what
killed me he goes you're the first
person we've ever have say no to that
now I hope he's just being a car
salesman and he was lying to me and that
was his last-ditch effort to try to
convince me but the other part is he's
actually telling the truth it's just
like then what happens is what what this
is how they do it is most people are
dopes so they don't think and then what
happens is becomes a herd mentality and
all they got to do is get most of the
herd to start running over the [ __ ]
cliff and you you have to do it too
because if you don't then you're just
gonna be [ __ ] sitting there all by
yourself like hey I'm not gonna have a
cellphone hey I'm not gonna have this
I'm not gonna have that and then your
life the way you're gonna lead it
becomes extremely limited the next thing
you know you're [ __ ] half naked
walking around your backyard trying to
like trap squirrels so you can eat that
day because you're not doing what
everybody else is doing and it's just
you know it's gonna be the worst is when
they try to convince when they try to
convince people to do it right there's
gonna be some politician getting it with
that [ __ ] smile on his face where
he's like I don't want to do this but I
have to do this I have to do this so I
can go on the post president [ __ ] you
know $70,000,000 speaking tour where I
go out and I give speeches to the same
[ __ ] people that put me into office
like the hero of all heroes presidents
Obama is about to do he just he has that
[ __ ] has 69 million dollars with
the gigs on the books coming up you know
I will never for the life of me
understand why that guy people like
liberals look at that guy like he
[ __ ] did something for him I will
never get that it's like that guy had
his face in the pig trough just like
everybody else I mean I don't know I
don't know what it is I think it's
because he's sandwiched between two of
the worst public speakers of all time
bush and [ __ ] Trump you know what I
mean I think if he came after Clinton
where Clinton wasn't the greatest oh ho
ho
but he got enough the women [ __ ]
loved him I will never get that either
how much women love that [ __ ] big
[ __ ] baby he we look at goofball
jesus bell there any presidents that you
liked yeah I lighted mine the first
George Bush the [ __ ] war hero and I
liked I liked Jimmy Carter